[Musica]
avete mai rivolto il vostro sguardo
verso il cielo verso le stelle il buio
profondo oppure verso il sole le nuvole
chiedendomi che cosa ci sia al di là del
nostro pianeta domande come questa mi
hanno sempre affascinata fin da bambina
e mi hanno spinta sebbene il mio
percorso di studi non sia sempre stato
di tipo scientifico dato che ho un
diploma linguistico e una laurea in
clarinetto mi hanno spinta verso appunto
l'ingegneria aerospaziale
me l'hanno fatto innamorare quindi la
poi scelta come percorso di studi questo
amore per lo spazio è arrivato in
particolar modo al termine delle scuole
superiori in quel momento della vita di
una persona in cui si deve scegliere che
cosa fare del proprio futuro e assieme
ad esso rimetta la consapevolezza di
voler dedicare la mia vita al qualcosa
di particolare di affascinante in grado
di mettermi alla prova di far emergere
le mie capacità
già al termine della laurea triennale
sono riuscita ad entrare a far parte di
un progetto che ha dato una svolta
importantissima la mia vita ovvero star
assieme ad altri quattro studenti
dell'università di padova sono infatti
riusciti ad ideare un meccanismo per lo
svolgimento e di riavvolgimento di un
filo nello spazio e questo meccanismo a
numerosissime applicazioni ne vediamo
però assieme una forse la più
affascinante è la più urgente che è il
problema dei detriti spaziali
la ricerca in campo spaziale ha portato
negli anni a delle conseguenze che sono
spesso state ignorate ma che per le
quali la nostra generazione rischia di
dover pagare un prezzo decisamente molto
alto non tutti sanno che sopra le nostre
teste orbita una quantità elevatissima
di oggetti parliamo di serbatoi per il
propellente vuoti di satelliti non più
funzionanti ed i componenti minori per
tradurre il tutto con un'immagine comune
ed attuali se passati in pochi anni ad
avere un disabitato e il iliaco
paesaggio naturale ad una vera e propria
metropoli di detriti introducendo
qualche numero
parliamo di circa 18.000
di dimensioni rilevanti di circa 750
mila oggetti di dimensioni medie e circa
colleghi una moneta e di milioni di
oggetti inferiori ad un centimetro
il vero problema è che solo il 67 per
cento di essi è funzionante
quindi il 1100 satelliti circa il
restante 94 per cento è costituito da
materiale che nel corso degli anni è
stato accumulato nello spazio e che ora
vaga incontro al lato quindi potete ben
capire quanto sia rischioso impattare
contro uno di essi e questo rappresenta
un problema decisamente importante per
le emissioni attuali ma anche per quelle
future
ora immaginate di avere in mano una
nocciolina e che è più o meno la
dimensione di un detrito medio e di
poterla lanciare contro un altro oggetto
ad una velocità di 35.000 40.000
chilometri orari una cosa di tutti i
giorni insomma l'effetto contro questo
altro oggetto sarebbe equiparabile non a
quello di un incidente stradale o di uno
sparo di un proiettile ma quello di una
granata
lascio quindi alla vostra immaginazione
la cosa potrebbe portare l'impatto
contro un detrito delle dimensioni di un
camion quindi con questa immagine ben
chiare in testa
potete capire bene la gravità del
problema dei detriti spaziali che cosa
fare quindi di fronte ad un problema di
coinvolgimento globale di questo tipo
già da alcuni anni la nasa l'agenzia
spaziale europea e la comunità
internazionale hanno adottato delle
norme e delle procedure per poter
limitare il problema dei detriti
però queste non sono sufficienti non
sono sufficienti senza la rimozione
attiva dei detriti e quindi parliamo
dell'intervento dell'uomo
il vero problema è come fare questa
rimozione attiva infatti ogni meccanismo
deve avere delle caratteristiche
particolari deve essere tecnologicamente
costruibile economicamente appetibile e
cosa più importante deve essere un buon
compromesso dal punto di vista politico
a livello internazionale superate queste
tre prove
queste caratteristiche deve non deve
costituire un rischio per poi la
popolazione a terra quindi capite bene
quanto sia complesso da affrontare
questo problema
nonostante questo sono state proposte
diverse soluzioni negli animi e ne
parliamo ad esempio di rieti o di vele
ma anche soluzioni un po più esotiche
in questo contesto si inserisce il
progetto di cui faccio parte quindi star
che è stato ideato da cinque studenti
dell'università di padova e che potete
vedere alle mie spalle e che ora vi
presento a partire dalla vostra a
sinistra trovate leonardo pellegrino
poi ci sono mattia pezzato e al centro
il nostro team leader gilberto grassi
quindi alvise rossi e poi io come
accennato star è un meccanismo per lo
srotolamento e l'avvolgimento di un filo
nello spazio questo meccanismo va poi
inserito all'interno di un satellite più
grande chiamato statale the madre che
grazie a questo filo può dare andare ad
agganciare questo detrito oggetto e per
poi riportarlo a terra oppure lanciarlo
diciamo verso l'infinito e dold la
nostra esperienza è iniziata nel 2015
quando il professore di impianti sistemi
aerospaziali di padova le sembra
francesconi ci ha suggerito di provare
uno di quei bandi che ogni anno
l'agenzia spaziale europea mette a
disposizione per gli studenti
universitari per avvicinarli giallo
dai primi anni alla ricerca in campo
spaziale quindi potete immaginare il
nostro entusiasmo di fronte a questa
proposta e quindi era nata anche la
voglia di mettersi poi in gioco e di
contribuire alla ricerca spaziale e dopo
circa un anno di studi e anche qualche
fallimento nel 2016
abbiamo avuto la straordinaria notizia
di essere stati selezionati proprio per
uno di questi bandi limando draw più
artesis che permette di testare il
proprio esperimento nella torre di
caduta di brema che vedete alle mie
spalle e che è una struttura una delle
strutture che si sia sulla terra per
simulare la condizione di assenza di
peso dello spazio
come vedete si tratta di un'enorme torre
che viene svuotato dell'aria all'interno
della quale viene lanciata una capsula
contenente l'esperimento con due
modalità sei una prima modalità la
modalità drop con cui viene lasciata
cadere la capsula dall'altro e con cui
si sperimentano circa 4,7 secondi di
assenza di peso o la modalità a
catapulta che è quello quella di cui che
di cui ha usufruito star e che invece dà
accesso 9,3 secondi di assenza di peso
per non va alla nostra esperienza
noi al momento della selezione
ovviamente dopo un primo periodo di
totale euforia
ci siamo resi conto di aver pochissimo
tempo per portare quella che nel momento
della selezione era un'idea geniale ma
come completamente astratta a qualcosa
poi di concreto come previsto dal
programma infatti avevamo circa sette
mesi da marzo ad ottobre per passare
dalla fase idea alla fase poi di test e
la nostra poca esperienza nel campo
della ricerca però non era certo d'aiuto
noi infatti stavamo proponendo qualcosa
di estremamente innovativo è nuovo e
quindi non c'erano dei libri su cui
studiare o delle missioni passate a cui
appoggiarsi al cento per cento
grazie però l'input iniziale del nostro
professore dei suoi dottorandi
l'ingegner riccardo mantellato siamo
riusciti a sviluppare le prime idee ad
arrivare in poco tempo ad un concetto
finale per la progettazione ci siamo
ispirati ad un meccanismo
sconosciutissimo la canna da pesca e
l'abbiamo poi adattata allo spazio cosa
che magari a una prima impressione può
sembrare un po banale ma in realtà
quello che il nostro team si è trovato
ad affrontare è stata una vera e propria
sfida nei confronti di anni di studio e
in effetti nel passato tutte le missioni
che hanno utilizzato dei figli avevano
dei meccanismi enormi e molto pesanti
nei quali filo spesso si inceppava si
trancia va quindi portando poi al
fallimento della missione la nostra
bravura invece è stata proprio quella di
adottare un meccanismo semplice e
leggero allo spazio non abbiamo mai
smesso di credere di poterlo realizzare
nonostante tutto cosa che ci ha aiutati
nei sette mesi dato che comunque le
difficoltà che abbiamo affrontato sono
state decisamente numerose parliamo ad
esempio di soluzioni che poi si sono
rivelate non vincenti
oppure di ordini che hanno da riparare o
scarsa collaborazione con aziende con
terze persone e fondi in realtà che in
un primo momento erano quasi inesistenti
e che ci hanno a volte addirittura
impedito di comprare la componentistica
necessaria in qualche modo però siamo
riusciti ad adattarci alle situazioni
quindi trovando delle soluzioni
alternative meno costose e in un primo
momento quasi autofinanziandoci alla
fine di settembre però il nostro
esperimento andava costruito in qualche
modo e alla fine ce l'abbiamo fatta con
decisamente molti caffè in corpo e anche
qualche notte un po insonne però alla
fine di settembre il nostro esperimento
era concreto era lì davanti a noi e
quindi siamo poi volati a brema per due
delle settimane che forse
sono tra le settimane più
indimenticabili della nostra vita
durante la prima settimana abbiamo avuto
modo di confrontarci con i tecnici e gli
esperti della torre di caduta che ci
hanno dato tantissimi consigli e stato
un asse una settimana veramente molto
educativa e durante la quale abbiamo
apportato le ultime migliorie al nostro
esperimento l'abbiamo poi inserito
all'interno della capsula che vedete al
termine della prima settimana quindi il
nostro esperimento era pronto per quello
che poi sarebbe stato il vero cuore del
nostro progetto
quindi la settimana dei lanci terna un
doppio 51 al giorno questa settimana il
giorno tipo prevedeva la sveglia presto
una controllata generale
dell'esperimento e quindi magari la
sostituzione di qualche componente poi
vi era l'inserimento all'interno della
torre e il lancio al termine del lancio
e veniva poi nuovamente inserita l'aria
all'interno della torre veniva
recuperata la capsula e in serata c'era
quindi l'analisi del comportamento ed
eventuali modifiche per il lancio
successivo
ora immaginate di condensare sette mesi
di lavoro di fatiche di sogni a volte
anche un po di disperazione di speranze
in 9 secondi e potrete avvicinarvi in
quel che potrete avvicinarvi a quella
che era la nostra sensazione all'inizio
di questa seconda settimana e quel
bottone rosso però ormai andavo ha
premuto e dare il via quindi alla
sequenza di lancio che avrebbe svelato
se quei sette mesi poi avrebbero portato
a dei frutti
qui eravamo all'interno della torre di
controllo
[Musica]
come avete potuto vedere in questo video
vecchio come avete potuto vedere in
questo video
siamo orgogliosi di dire che il nostro
esperimento ha avuto successo in tutti e
cinque i lanci ed è un risultato che ha
superato anche le più rosee delle
aspettative e ha lasciato spazio a
diversi progetti per il nostro futuro
e in effetti abbiamo da poco depositato
il brevetto del nostro meccanismo c'è
spazio per nuovi studi approfondimenti e
ci saranno poi delle pubblicazioni e
stiamo anche raccogliendo dei fondi per
partecipare a delle conferenze nazionali
ed internazionali per i quali ci hanno
già selezionati a conclusione di tutto
ci tengo a sottolineare quanto ognuno di
noi abbia speso energie e sogni per
questo progetto sacrificando tantissime
ore di lavoro e di studio e di
divertimento cosa che non tutti i 23
anni al giorno d'oggi sono disposti a
fare siamo partiti da un'idea
completamente astratta su un foglio
senza fondi senza conoscere veramente
nel dettaglio l'oggetto di ciò che
stavamo creando e senza conoscerci e
nemmeno benissimo tra di noi per
arrivare poi ad essere un team unito e
con un sogno comune e quindi siamo fieri
di aver dimostrato che con l'impegno la
determinazione e la passione
i risultati prima o poi a tipino noi non
sappiamo se il nostro meccanismo verrà
mai considerato da qualche agenzia
spaziale o se volerà la cosa importante
però è che ognuno di noi ha cercato e
sta tuttora cercando di scrivere un
piccolo pezzettino di storia e chi lo sa
magari in un futuro non troppo lontano
potremo dire di aver contribuito a far
ritornare lo spazio un posto libero e
incontaminato come tutti noi ce lo
immaginiamo
[Musica]
[Applauso]